Знімальний майданчик…
Тут буде стояти стіл…
…він міняє на депутатську трибуну.
Урочистість може бути в перший день, а далі робота, робота і робота…
Новообраний депутат Роман Грищук відомий українцям як шоумен, телеведучий
та керівник гумористичної студії "Мамахохотала",
який створює вечірні телешоу, серіали та вірусні ролики.
Тепер його колеги по сцені не лише виступають без нього, але й кепкують з його політичної кар'єри.
Справа в тому, що Романа Грищука з нами немає.
Він тепер у кращому місці.
У Верховній Раді.
Тому я пропоную пом’янути його хвилиною мовчання.
Роман виступав у КВК ще зі шкільних часів.
Не полишив хобі і під час навчання у КПІ на медико-інженерному факультеті.
За фахом жодного дня не працював.
Єдине місце роботи, вказане у трудовій книжці - студія "Мамахохотала".
Комік, який може сам написати жарт, - доволі глибока людина, яка вміє рефлексувати,
переживати і розуміє сьогодення, суспільство, проблеми.
І вміє не просто це показати, а показати через жарт ставлення до цього.
Сім років присвятив розвиткові студії, яку сам заснував.
І ось звільняється з посади директора за власним бажанням.
Я на початку літа навіть про це й не думав…
Що мені хочеться зробити за ці п'ять років - щоб змінилося ставлення до народного депутата.
Не те, що це має бути пузатий дядько, в якого купа грошей
і який іде туди захищати свої інтереси.
Ним може стати будь-яка людина, тому що це просто представник народу.
На вибори Роман пішов від партії "Слуга народу"
за 222-им мажоритарним округом, це Солом’янський район Києва.
З відривому майже у три рази він обігнав депутата останніх двох скликань Дмитра Андрієвського,
якого в русі ЧЕСНО називають "гречкосієм"
та підозрюють у ймовірній причетності до корупційних схем.
Я - останній мажоритарник.
Якби не революціяЗе-команди, то не реально було б вигнати.
Вони ж чому ухвалювали цей виборчий кодекс, який залишає мажоритарку?
Тому що були абсолютно впевнені, що на мажоритарці нікому нічого не світить,
тому що округи "засіяні" і є повний адмінресурс.
Виборці Романа - переважно розчаровані у владі люди.
Зеленського вже купили олігарх и…
Уже все, Пінчук.
Нічого не буде.
Цих Бойко всіх під мітлу, вони в ж старі… Вороги часів Януковича.
Роман хоче бути іншим депутатом, з новими підходами і не підвести довіру людей.
Щоправда, поки, як і більшість "слуг народу",
лише критикує минулу владу, зокрема за повільних хід реформ.
У Верховній Раді він займатиметься освітою,
Мені освіта близька, я люблю навчатися. Я зі школи мріяв ще працювати вчителем…
Та чи достатньо цього, аби займатися системними змінами в освіті на рівні всієї держави?
Нині Роман лише знайомиться із законодавчими ініціативами попереднього комітету освіти і науки.
Перша зустріч з депутатами та профільним міністром має відбутися до 29 серпня,
першого засідання Верховної Ради 9-го скликання.
Поки фантазує на тему, що треба змінити в освіті.
От у мене така мрія: "Основи підприємництва" ввести в школах Солом’янського району.
Можливо, онлайн-курс зробити.
Подивитись, як це працює в рамках одного району, чи є зворотний зв’язок, чи був корисним предмет.
Доопрацювати курс і потім поширити на всю Україну.
Депутатськими пільгами, приміром, на житло чи на проїзд, обіцяє не користуватися.
Про інші лише жартує…
Я ще читав, що безкоштовні похорони.
Це мені люди на районі розказали на районі, коли були зустрічі, що запровадили. 20 тисяч гривень.
Він переконаний, що подібні привілеї, як і депутатську недоторк анність,
нова Верховна Рада скасує.
Принаймні Роман за такі зміни обіцяє голосувати.
А ось заробітну плату депутата з часом, каже, треба переглянути.
Нині парламентарі отримують до 40 тисяч гривень.
Це питання, яке лежить у зоні популізму, це не перше, що треба робити.
Перше - треба повернути довіру людей до Верховної Ради,
до того, що цей орган може працювати і що він корисний і правильний,
а вже після цього повернутись до цього питання.
Поки Роман не вирішив, чи залишиться в політиці довше ніж на п’ять років.
Хоче працювати задля реальних змін
та сподівається, що монобільшість "Слуги народу" у Верховній Раді
дозволить швидше втілювати реформи в життя.
А ось шоу повністю покидати не планує.
Друзі, може, не треба сваритись?
Ну ми ж домовлялись з вами, що залишимось однією дружньою командою.
І обіцяє своїм фанам час від часу з'являтися на сцені.
Закон цього не забороняє.